- [Narrator] The New Hampshire primary
is just around the corner.
- This is potentially a pivotal moment
in the Republican primary.
- [Narrator] For Nikki Haley,
New Hampshire could be
her best and last chance
to persuade voters that
she's a better alternative
to Donald Trump.
Here's why.
The first primary of
the 2024 election season
is now a one-on-one battle
after Florida governor Ron DeSantis
suspended his presidential bid
two days before the election
and endorsed former
president Donald Trump.
- I can't ask our supporters
to volunteer their time
and donate their resources
if we don't have a clear path to victory.
- [Narrator] The New Hampshire
primary comes off the heels
of the Republican caucuses in Iowa,
where Trump won by a
record breaking margin,
all but cementing his
position as the front runner
for the party's nomination.
- We wanna thank the great people of Iowa.
Thank you. We love you all.
(crowd cheering)
- [Narrator] But unlike Iowa,
New Hampshire has a more
moderate electorate,
and large numbers of independents
are allowed to vote in
the state's GOP primary.
- New Hampshire's much
more independent-minded,
much more secular.
This has always been a state
where the electorate
was much more friendly
to the appeal of someone like Nikki Haley,
who combines a sort of conservative stance
on taxes and spending,
with conservative
positions on foreign policy
and a pitch that's about electability.
There's a substantial block
of Democratic-leaning independents,
who might like to take the nomination away
from Donald Trump.
There's a substantial block
of moderate conservatives
or conservative-leaning independents.
All of these moderate
voters are a potential asset
for a candidate like Nikki Haley.
- [Narrator] With
DeSantis out of the race,
Haley has the opportunity
to present herself
as the better and now
only alternative to Trump.
- It has been the conventional wisdom
that the only way Trump could be beaten
is if he were one-on-one
with a single alternative,
giving voters that binary choice,
either it's Trump or it's not.
- Do we want more of the same
or do you want something different?
And more of the same isn't just Joe Biden,
more of the same is also Donald Trump.
- [Narrator] Haley believes
she already has momentum
going into the New Hampshire primary.
- She has the endorsement
of the very popular
Republican governor of New
Hampshire, Chris Sununu,
who's been very outspoken against Trump
and what he represents.
- [Narrator] Haley is
also likely to scoop up
some supporters of former
New Jersey governor,
Chris Christie, an avid Trump critic
who dropped out of the race
just days before the Iowa caucuses.
However, Trump remains dominant
in polls in New Hampshire
and the states to follow
for future primaries.
With DeSantis endorsing Trump
after suspending his campaign,
the support he was
drawing in New Hampshire
will likely go to Trump,
widening his lead.
Another decisive victory could
make the former president
nearly impossible to stop.
- From the perspective
of the Trump campaign,
this is already over.
You have a lot of Trump's
allies and campaign officials
saying, "It's time to unite
the Republican Party."
Haley has tried to toe
this very delicate line of,
on the one hand, articulating
what she believes
are valid criticisms of Trump,
while not angering the voters
who still think that
Trump was a good president
and like him in a lot of ways.
And so for her, it's really
New Hampshire that's do or die.
She needs to either win
or show that she can come
close to Donald Trump
to give her a reason
to keep going forward.
- [Narrator] It's still early
in the 2024 presidential campaign season,
with many more state
primaries and caucuses to go
ahead of November's election.
But New Hampshire will likely set the tone
for another major upcoming task,
the South Carolina primary.
- Trump looks very strong
throughout the South,
including in South Carolina.
We've seen him get huge reception
when he's gone down there to campaign.
So although it is Nikki
Haley's home state,
where she was a popular governor,
it's viewed as an uphill battle
for all the non-Trump candidates.
If Haley is able to come close
or defeat Trump in New Hampshire,
she really looks like
a much more of a force
in this campaign,
and it starts to look like a real contest.
Now, she still has an uphill
battle in South Carolina,
but at least it looks
like an actual battle.
(gentle music)